Timothy, what's the status with the Linear Solutions?
Could you give us the latest on the Square project?
The Linear Solutions department has yet again functioned at full capacity...
...and we have fulfilled 114 percent of this month's objectives.
Overall, we have very good progress with the design.
Are we on track with the schedule?
When are we required to start delivering?
I'm happy to report that we are ready to start first deliveries tomorrow,...
...which is way ahead of the requested delivery schedule.
We've only just finished system testing the prototype...
...and are only halfway through performance testing.
We haven't even released an alpha version yet.
As I said earlier, we've had very good progress with the design.
Yes, we've had very good progress; but I'd say the design of the product is only 75 percent complete.
Well, exactly.
That's 3 out of every 4.
So, we're ready to start shipping tomorrow.
What?
It doesn't work like that.
We'll produce, say, 4 units, but only ship the first 3!
Then, when you're finally 100 percent complete with the design,...
...we can then ship the fourth.
Excellent work, Timothy!
You can proceed with the production.
Anderson, send me, please a revised delivery schedule, so I can share it with the client.
Well, thank you, everyone! This was very productive.
Yet again!